the one thing that makes me fearful here  is that chucky  he lost in round one against prague  because he forgot that the knight could  retreat and block and  knights being so tricky in uh blitz and  speed chess as you said there ivanka  that's  a  potential wow incredible to move what a  move by a van truck beautiful bang that  wins the game now the black king is  distracted deflected away and the white  sea pawn is going to push him making you  queen i saw him i saw him mumble put  that in your pipe and smoke it  i'm sure he just mumbled that  that's a move to be proud of i can't  believe i mean that wasn't on my road  i've got to admit i mean there were  other moves there but uh there we go he  takes the win at vanchak a stylish and  brutal victory in the end incredible  stuff  ivanciak wins another game and this one  against one of the very top players in  the world and each gear is shaking his  head  he got struck by some evangel genius  in this game